[Musica]
[Applauso]
ognuno dovrebbe avere la propria luce
una frase molto bella chi la sente ne
apprezza Istintivamente la densità il
fascino la potenza ognuno dovrebbe
brillare o meglio Ogni esistenza ha il
diritto Di splendere sicuramente Sempre
chi ascolta penserà l'avrà detta un
intellettuale un filosofo uno
scrittore gli uomini non sono nati per
essere delle talpe o per essere trattati
da talpe per vivere al buio ognuno
dovrebbe avere la propria
luce la frase non è stata detta da una
persona importante ma da due bambini
Giovanni Carpene e Ugo Anselmi su un
giornalino scolastico piccole Dolomiti
autoprodotto nel 195 qu da un maestro
Gianni Fae e dai suoi Scolari di
Sant'Andrea di Badia Calavena un povero
Borgo delle Prealpi Veronesi la lego per
intero Nel suo contesto nel nostro paese
molte contrade sono senza luce alla sera
devono illuminare la casa con una
Lucerna l'anno scorso avevamo avevano
detto che avrebbero fatto venire la luce
dove manca ognuno dovrebbe avere la
propria
luce la frase perde di colpo il su alone
polisemico per ritornare al suo
significato letterale crudo ognuno
dovrebbe avere l'energia elettrica nella
propria casa Giovanni Ugo quarta
elementare chiedevano che una conquista
della modernità la luce potesse essere
di tutti senza distinzioni Perché alcuni
ce l'avevano e altri no a Sant'Andrea
non c'erano la farmacia non c'era il
telefono l'acqua corrente in casa non un
teatro un cinema parrocchiale
unico presidio culturale La scuola
elementare e il suo giovane maestro i
suoi allievi erano bambini abituati a
lavorare nei campi non era facile
interessarli allo studio Nelle lunghe
ore passate a scuola Si distraevano si
annoiavano E allora cosa facevano
prendevano dalla tasca un coltellino e
iniziavano a intagliare i banchi un cane
un albero un fiore un trattore una
sgranatrice quando il maestro
non li
sgridò Anzi stupito dalla loro bravura
portò in classe delle tavolette di
linoleum e le distribuì per far
realizzare loro delle vere incisioni poi
ebbe l'idea addirittura di fondare un
giornalino
scolastico gli strumenti erano poveri I
coltellini le tavolette di linoleum dei
Semplici Massi per pressare le la carta
l'acqua dell'abbeveratoio pubblico e dei
fili dove stendere ed asciugare i fogli
con delle mollette per i panni con poco
il maestro riuscì ad accendere la luce
della loro curiosità e della
Fantasia mentre i bambini di Fae
allestivano una tipografia antelitteram
primordiale ante Gutenberg agli inizi
del 53 un poeta famoso e poliedrico di
formazione scientifica Leonardo
sinisgalli fondava a Roma una rivista
intitolata civiltà delle macchine
fortemente
innovativa era il periodo della
Ricostruzione postbellica la guerra
ormai era un ricordo L'interesse per la
tecnica e la scienza da parte di
sinisgalli il poeta ingegnere era
straordinariamente forte anche per gli
sviluppi che se andavano comiendo in
quegli anni sul nucleare per la
conquista dello spazio per l'automazione
crescente nelle fabbriche e nella vita
domestica per le frontiere della
cibernetica della statistica applicata
alla produzione economica e
industriale civiltà delle macchine nelle
mani del suo ideatore divenne una Forgia
sperimentale di altiss livello che andò
oltre il proprio compito di promozione
aziendale per inseguire invece come
obiettivo la contaminazione culturale
l'esaltazione dell'approccio Politecnico
il dialogo tra la poesia l'arte
l'architettura l'armonia dei saperi
coinvolse per questo le menti più
brillanti del secolo dai poeti ai
matematici dai fisici agli artisti dagli
inventori ai filosofi dagli urbanisti ai
te tecnici la macchina per lo spirito
del tempo e per Leonardo sinisgalli
divenne la cerniera il simbolo di
un'antropologia il cui obiettivo puntava
a saldare i valori dell'uomo con le
frontiere di una società sempre più
industrializzata fatto non solo di
capannoni ma anche di tempo libero e di
comodità grazie alle automobili ai
frigoriferi alle televisioni le
lavatrici le Lambrette sinisgalli era
l'apice del suo successo quando
ricevette da Sant'Andrea di Badia vena
un'incisione di una scolara Carmela
Marana che era accompagnata da un testo
che parlava di macchine le macchine
semplici che venivano utilizzate dalle
proprie famiglie povere e Sinis gali si
incuriosì e ne nacque una
corrispondenza e quando giunsero in
redazione nel maggio del
1954 il giornalino e le lineografia
sulle macchine cisgale scrisse su di
loro proprio su civiltà delle macchine
un lungo e commosso
articolo senti che la fiducia in un
mondo nuovo fatto di macchine di
progresso tecnologico quell' adesione
per l'avvento di una nuova civiltà non
solo coincidevano con la sua missione
culturale ma provenivano da una delle
zone più povere più Periferiche più
desolate dell'Italia e se quindi
L'importanza di una nuova civiltà delle
macchine veniva percepita da un manipolo
di bambini di un territorio desolato e
periferico Beh allora significava che vi
era una vera e propria necessità storica
che Il sogno di un nuovo Umanesimo
tecnologico potesse trasformarsi in
realtà Leonardo sinisgalli il poeta
famoso quello che era il profeta della
civiltà delle macchine per ringraziarli
donò a questi piccoli incisori di
Sant'Andrea un torchio per la stampa e
una manciata di caratteri mobili così da
rendere meno faticosa e più rapida la
stampa del loro giornalino scolastico
offrì loro una macchina una leva di
progresso una luce in quella luce in
quella scuola rurale Senza luce
elettrica la scuola di Gianni Fae in
breve tempo divenne famosissima in
Italia e all'estero per anni se ne
interessarono La Stampa italiana e
straniera la radio e la televisione i
loro disegni vennero apprezzati e
premiati da critici galleristi e artisti
sinisgalli definì l'incontro tra i
bambini e le macchine come l'incontro
dell'innocenza col miracolo del lavoro
nell'officina e nel cantiere i bambini
avevano ino grazie al loro Candore una
grande verità
ossia che la macchina deve dare sollievo
al lavoro ma ad una condizione che la
macchina non diventi l'antagonista della
natura che che la si completi e la si
integri in questa civiltà delle macchine
rappresentò il simbolo dell'osmosi tra
le due culture quella industriale e
quella umanistica prima ancora che il
celebre saggio di Snow venisse tradotto
in Italia nel
1959 Sinis Gale era convinto che la
tecnica dev essere continuamente nutrita
di cultura la cultura diceva deve
salvarci dai pericoli insiti
nell'eccesso di potere dato alle
macchine e difendere la sempre più
precaria libertà dell'uomo nel suo lungo
matrimonio con l'industria il poeta
ingegnere sepre guadagnarsi la stima e
la fiducia di formidabili Capitani
d'industria Giuseppe Luraghi Adriano
livetti Alberto Pirelli condivisero con
lui una visione che andava oltre la
logica aziendale della chiusura dei
bilanci in attivo alla fine dell'anno
anno la loro idea di società industriale
si basava su una cultura
interdisciplinare ed educante che poteva
stimolare in ognuno la luce dell'umanità
dell'Autonomia della dignità del lavoro
e della Libertà Giuseppe Luraghi
amministratore delegato di film
meccanica era convinto che l'accusa di
forza disumana e disumanizzante che si
rivolgeva alla tecnologia dipendesse da
un'incomprensione storica che aveva
diviso da sempre la cultura umanistica e
la cultura tecnica come se regni
dell'intelligenza fossero due nettamente
distinti e opposti
Eppure aggiunge l'umanità progredisce
tanto in virtù della Scienza e della
Tecnica quanto in virtù dell'arte e
della cultura scienziati e tecnici non
potrebbero sviluppare la loro capacità
senza un'apertura sugli orizzonti della
Fantasia dell'immaginazione il mondo è
cambiato da allora anche le macchine
sono cambiate siamo stati catapultati in
una nuova dimensione veloce leggera
senza confini instabile problematica e
liquida dall'analogico al digitale dal
materiale all'immateriale il mondo ce lo
siamo ritrovati in tasca nell'imbuto di
uno Smartphone in una mano con la sua
luce digitale sono mutati i lavori il
tempo libero il modo di comunicare
persino i contrasti e i conflitti tra
gli stati sono condizionati dalle nuove
tecnologie dal controllo dei
semiconduttori delle nano tecnologie e
delle terre rare
Alessandro Aresi nel suo ultimo saggio
il dominio del 2O secolo Cina Stati
Uniti e la guerra invisibile sulla
tecnologia dopo aver analizzato il
conflitto in corso tra le due
superpotenze si è posto una domanda è da
romantici pensare che questo passaggio
storico geopolitico e tecnologico
necessiti anche di un nuovo metodo
culturale con la scusa del dubbio ha
proposto un'ipotesi
Forse dice ci manca la curiosità che ha
animato le imprese di Luraghi e
sinisgalli l'idea di un'anima della
Ricostruzione che mette insieme sul
serio Il furor matematicus e la profonda
ricerca
umanistica la differenza sostanziale
rispetto al passato che le nuove
macchine digitali non sono strumenti ma
sono diventate un ambiente all'interno
del quale viviamo in permanente
interazione tra noi e gli altri Ma al di
là della natura delle macchine semplici
o digitali occorre sempre un
un timone culturale che dia un orizzonte
e una
direzione in termini di valori non
deperibili nel tempo che indichi la
strada per una nuova civiltà in cui le
macchine anche quelle intelligenti siano
sempre al servizio dell'umanità e non
strumento di oppressione o di
esasperazione delle uguaglianze
sinisgalli stesso nel 1953 aveva scritto
è logico che la quantità spaventosa di
energia che si consuma sarebbe tutta
sprecata se non servisse almeno a
procurare un giocattolo all'ultimo
bambino
Lucano proprio perché il mondo
continuerà a cambiare bisogna umanamente
ancorarsi a un metodo quello che
sinisgalli e Luraghi nel contesto del
boom economico animati da un romantico
entusiasmo avevano intuito il progresso
non deve inseguire ad ogni costo
profitto e potere Ma alleviare la fatica
dell'uomo e promuoverne l'elevamento
economico culturale e sociale
serve una forcia culturale che sappia
fondere in una originale lega alchemica
e nelle giuste dosi poesia e scienza
istinto e razionalità calcolo e fantasia
la nuova civiltà digitale deve
armonizzarsi integrarsi con la natura e
con l'uomo senza antagonismi e in modo
sostenibile solo un Umanesimo digitale
che non mette in discussione la
superiorità dell'uomo come essere
Pensante ed emozionante sull'algoritmo
può diventare l'arch di una nuova
società basata sulla luce di una
consapevolezza che illumini sia Le
straordinarie possibilità che I
terribili rischi di tutte le nuove
macchine L'alternativa è il baratro
della cecità quella che magistralmente
tragicamente è stata raccontata dal
Premio Nobel José Saramago ognuno
dovrebbe avere la propria luce non siamo
nati per essere delle talpe
Grazie
[Musica]
C